les choses doivent changer
mais réparer des siècles de justice
d'exclusion et de violences ça se fait
pas du jour au lendemain il faut
travailler ensemble il faut travailler
fort
plusieurs politiciens et de grandes
entreprises ont démontré leur soutien
aux communautés noires dans les derniers
jours
ce soir on se demande quelle est la
place des communautés noires dans
l'économie les entreprises les autres
directions avec nous pour en parler
carla beauvais qui est entrepreneur
social et cofondatrice d'origine village
bonsoir madame bové concert mais c'est
fignon avant de vous poser des questions
sur la situation actuelle d'abord
origines village qu'est ce que c'est en
fait si la plateforme qui a été fondé
l'année dernière qui avait pour but
d'aider les entrepreneurs des
communautés noires à s'émanciper
économie économiquement via dédié à la
technologie
donc c'est de développer des outils
technologiques qui pourraient permettre
aux entrepreneurs issus des communautés
noires de pouvoir se développer et
prendre leur place sur le marché et en
parallèle aussi de vraiment encouragé le
mouvement
by black le mouvement consommer local
mais consommer aussi des entrepreneurs
qui provient des communautés noires
donc si les deux missions principales de
l'eau sbl qu'est ce que vous pensez des
déclarations de monsieur trudeau par
exemple de politiciens d'entreprise
également qu'ils disent vouloir
favoriser de véritables changements qui
viennent donc des politiciens des
grandes entreprises que ce que vous
pensez de ces déclarations dans les
dernières heures et dans les derniers
jours je pense que on arrive à un
carrefour voit ce que les gens je pense
que l'indignation collective qu'on peut
voir par rapport à ce qui s'est passé à
minneapolis ça vraiment réveillé
certaines personnes et faire en sorte
qu'on n'a pas le choix nécessairement de
se positionner plus de dire qu'on veut
combattre les injustices sociales
maintenant il ya eu beaucoup de huy a eu
beaucoup de
d'allocutions qui ont été faites
beaucoup de discours mais un peu
d'actions concrètes encore donc je pense
que comme monsieur trudeau dans les clés
d'un titre hugo disait ça va prendre du
temps mais on espère vraiment que c'est
ces discours là vont se transformer en
actions concrètes riel très rapidement
et je doute je doute aussi parfois de
qu'on regarde convoi le commentaire de
monsieur legault par exemple qui disait
qu'il était content les quotas pour pour
dans la fonction publique
donc ça pour moi c'est un ange est de
taille parce que s'il ya des problèmes
systémiques il faut trouver des soldes
et des solutions quand même assez
drastiques pour pouvoir remettre ballon
c'est donc je pense que oui il ya du
positif il voir les choses du bon côté
mais les actions se il va falloir qu'on
voit des actions aussi parce que mon
analyse du canada dit souvent qu'il le
dit encore ce matin il y a un problème
de racisme systémique
le premier ministre du québec dit qu'il
ne veux pas qualifier les choses de
cette façon il dit que la majorité des
québécois ne sont pas racistes
qu'est ce que vous en pensez écoutez
c'est clair que je pense qu'on peut
faire de la sémantique tant qu'on veut
peut-être que monsieur legault ne veut
pas utiliser les mots parce que
peut-être que le mot raciste systémique
s'affaisse a fait part peut-être que ça
ça mais une culture une cale une
culpabilité mais en fait ce que ça veut
dire en fait c'est que des barrières
sociales
il ya des clôtures invisible qu'on doit
surmonter et elles seront structurelles
donc je pense pas que si monsieur
legault on lui venait en face toutes les
statistiques qui prouvent qu'il ya des
injustices qui prouve qu'il ya des
inégalités qui prouve que des disparités
peut dire que si ces faits l'homme
n'existe pas donc qu'il ne qu'il qui
décide pas nommer les choses par leurs
vrais par leurs frais terme parce que
c'est vraiment réellement cessé sa
change pas le fait que ça existait et
que c'est lent donc pour moi c'est
dommage ne pas avoir cette ce courage
politique de nommer les choses mais la
réalité c'est que face à ces
statistiques là il va falloir que le
gouvernement autant québec et au canada
crème des 10
vision qui vont faire en sorte que six
communautés marginalisées vont pouvoir
vraiment s'émanciper prélèveront toute
cette réalité quelle est la place des
gens des communautés noires dans le
monde des affaires de l'investissement
les conseils d'administration les postes
de direction par exemple pour la
fonction publique
on parle dans les postes de hauts
fonctionnaires
ces 23 personnes sur 124 qui sont issus
la diversion
pardon on a raté le 23 personnes sur 7
124 700 fonctionnaires
exactement je parle du mec donc on veut
et ce aux époques que les 23 personnes
ne sont pas issus des communautés non
c'est vraiment la diversité au total et
dans les cadres de la fonction publique
c'est 4 9% seulement contrairement à 33
% de la population
donc on voit vraiment qu'un déséquilibre
si on parle en termes de statistiques
économiques c'est 12 % du taux de
chômage dans les communautés noires
comparer à 5 % pour le reste de la
population
c'est encore pire pour les femmes noires
les statistiques sont encore plus plus
forte et plus l'écart est encore plus
grand pour les femmes noires donc
clairement il ya un problème et il ya
des enjeux
si on parle du côté des entreprises mais
y'a peu de ca qui ont des cadres des
gens sur leur conseil d'administration
qu'ils proviennent de la diversité
encore moins des communautés noires
s'est documenté on peut aller chercher
des statistiques à ce sujet là donc il
ya de l'oeil qui a fait un rapport
concret complet sur la diversité et
l'inclusion qui donna qui donne un
portrait quand même assez globale et
précise sur la situation dans les
entreprises et on voit clairement qu'il
ya une problématique au niveau de la
diversité et de l'inclusion dans l'eau
dans les grandes entreprises
je suis contente par des entreprises
faire des images par rapport à ce qu'ils
veulent faire mais il faut vraiment
qu'ils des actions il nourrit jusqu'à 35
secondes
vous avez décidé de prendre le taureau
par les cornes et de créer une sorte de
panier bleus n'est ce pas pour soutenir
des entreprises des les entrepreneurs
des communautés noires
en fait c'est pas du tout comme le
panier bleus louette c'est une facette
en fait le répertoire est une facette
d'un projet qui est beaucoup plus
globale c'est tout ce qu'on appelle ça
origines village c'est vraiment un
village technologie qu'on veut mettre à
la disposition le répertoire est un des
outils qu'on veut développer qui va
permettre aux entrepreneurs de pouvoir
se connecter et aux consommateurs de
pouvoir retrouver plus facilement ces
entreprises là donc c'est un outil c'est
pas du tout un panier bleus il ya
beaucoup d'autres éléments qui vont être
dévoilés au fur et à mesure ça s'appelle
origines village et l'application
s'appelle hop us une super parfait on
invite les gens à aller faire un tour là
tu es découvrir la suite des choses
carla beauvais merci beaucoup merci à
vous que l'invitation